vous n'imaginez pas l'impact que vont
avoir les robots sur vos vies dans le
futur on nous avait promis des
humanoïdes on nous avait promis des
voitures volantes mais aujourd'hui
l'arrêté la robotique c'est des galettes
qui aspire le sol la réalité de la
robotique c'est ça
c'est là quand même je vais pas
descendre mon sujet avant de vous en
parler mais comme vous l'avez vu même r2
d2 se déplace mieux que ces robots là
alors il ya un concept marketing qui dès
qu'on ne sait pas vraiment ce qu'on a
envie d'avoir tant qu'on ne l'a pas dans
les mains c'est particulièrement vrai en
ce qui concerne les robots c'est une
technologie qui est nouvelle et
aujourd'hui on est dans une phase
inconnu qui consiste à voir comment ces
petits robots vont entrer dans nos
foyers
car oui ils vont entrer dans vos foyers
par exemple programme de développement
du robot peppers eurogoals à 4000
personnes le possèdent ils sont en train
de développer sur ce robot la gibeau qui
est un robot américain 7500 unités djibo
vendus en financement participatif sur
internet et enfin mille robot body
le voici millogo veut dit encore une
fois c'est un financement participatif
qui s'est terminée et qu'ils vont
bientôt être prêt à se faire câliner
chez vous comme ce petit pelé au qui est
un petit robot fascinant et d'ailleurs
ce qui est fascinant avec ses robots
c'est qu'on peut développer une relation
avec eux alors qu'ils sont faits de
métal de plastique ou encore
d'électronique mais pas de chair et de
sang
celui là c'est un petit dinosaure qui
ressent tout ce que je fais quand je
fais des petites caresses comme ça ils
grognent il est content tu aimes bien
sort moi je travaille en robotique
depuis maintenant six ans et j'ai choisi
de travailler qu'une société qui
s'appelle aldebaran qui développe des
robots humanoïdes c'est les premiers
concepteurs de robots humanoïdes
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont créé un robot
qui s'appelle now et vous voyez ici
ils ont mis au centre de ce robot la
bienveillance et la bonté now c'est un
robot qui là pour améliorer la vie des
gens pour l'enrichir pour la rendre plus
heureuse ils sont là pour vous
accompagner pour assister mais pas pour
vous remplacer
d'ailleurs chaque développeur qui
s'engage à créer de l'application sur ce
robot là ils s'engagent à mener la
bienveillante dans son application est
pas conquérir le monde par exemple
maintenant il fait 58 centimes et 1 donc
ça va être compliqué
naos et à rohbock et curieux qui est
taquin mais qui n'est jamais méprisant
il est orienté vraiment pour interagir
avec l'homme alors si on revient un peu
avant dans l'histoire du robot compagnon
on a commencé avec aibo aillent bosser
un petit chien donc encore un animal qui
a été créé par sony en 1999
vraiment c'était un fort succès
commercial des départs puisque cinq
mille exemplaires sont partis en 20
minutes
sauf que voilà c'était encore très cher
il a peiné à rentrer dans les foyers
c'est resté vraiment l'apanage des
laboratoires et des autres écoles donc
il n'est pas vraiment arriver jusqu'à
nous aujourd'hui à deux facteurs sont en
train d'améliorer ça et qui font que
bientôt vous aurez des robots compagnons
le premier c'est l'évolution des
technologies de claude j ça va de mieux
en mieux les batteries ça tient de plus
en plus longtemps et le deuxième facteur
ce sont les coûts de ces pièces les
pièces coûtent de moins en moins chers
donc les robots val de moins en moins
cher et la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'en
france on est très bien placé on crée
des robots je vous ai parlé d'aldébaran
et de leurs deux robots mais il ya aussi
baudile vos robots que vous est présenté
tout à l'heure body arrive l'année
prochaine et vous pourrez l'acheter
entre 500 et 1000 euros les prés d'un
ordinateur
c'est vraiment accessible tout ça pour
vous dire pourquoi pas vous pourquoi est
ce que vous vous n'adoptez pas un robot
compagnon
c'est une technologie sociale alors je
vais vous raconter une anecdote pour
vous illustrer mes propos
nous avons conçu dans la société en bois
qui s'appelle sheldon que vous voyez là
grosse masse blanche qui est là c'est un
robot d'accueil il est là pour aller
vers les gens discuter avec eux et les
guider lors d'une prestation dans un
centre commercial sheldon a rencontré
baptiste que voilà ils ont passé un
super moment ensemble
et même on offrait des petits coeurs qui
représentait les coeurs des robots comme
ça aux enfants pour les remercier d'être
venu saluer sheldon et avoir passé un
bon moment et baptiste ne voulait
tellement pas quitter sheldon que
sheldon a été obligé de lui dire 'ne
t'inquiète pas dans quelques années tu
pourras m'adopter tu pourras m'avoir à
la maison quelques jours après moi j'ai
eu un coup de téléphone de la maman fait
deux baptistes qui m'a dit bonjour
maxime suis très embêté baptiste oublier
le petit coeur du robot et il m'a dit
maman comment est ce que je vais pouvoir
adopter un robot dans quelques années si
je suis même pas capable de ne pas
oublier son coeur j'ai vraiment compris
le lien qui avait tissé bâtisse avec ce
robot en à peine cinq minutes et que
c'était vraiment important pour lui la
véritable utilité de ces robots
compagnons
ce n'est pas de vous donner l'heure où
de relever vos mails ou même d'appeler
quelqu'un à distance avec de la
téléprésence ça vous pouvez le faire
avec un ordinateur mais c'est de donner
ses usages de manière sociale avec une
couche sociale supplémentaire
alors qu'est ce que j'entends par
déclencher ces nos réflexes sociaux en
faites vous là je vous parle de langage
corporel
on sait très bien que quand une personne
en face de nous adopte le même langage
que nous le même langage corporel que
nous alors on s'entend mieux plus
facilement avec cette personne quelqu'un
qui va venir qui va vous coller
immédiatement vous le connaissez pas
vous allez le rejeter
ce qui veut dire que lorsqu'un robot va
adopter le même langage corporel que
vous forcément la communication va se
faire beaucoup plus simplement quand un
robot baptisé les mêmes signaux que vous
vous allez comprendre
je vous donne un exemple si fait oui
comme ça
le robot zae comprendre dire tiens oui
il bat de la tête ça veut dire oui si
vous dis une crasse ou une petite blague
et qui fait un clin d'oeil vous dira
mais en plus il est doté d'humour ce
truc alors que c'est juste qu'on lui a
collé un clin d'oeil un tout simplement
ou encore quand on fait coucou comme
ceci si universelle pour dire bonjour
alors vous comprenez que le robot vous
salue nous utilisons nous les hommes ces
signaux pour déterminer à quel point on
va avoir un degré d'intimité avec cette
personne
eh bien c'est la même chose pour un
robot et d'ailleurs je vais vous le
montrer avec kiki qui est ce robot la
tiki bonjour est ce que tu peux te
présenter s'il te plaît mais bien sûr
maxime bonjour tout le monde je
m'appelle tiki et je suis très content
d'être à ted x clair aujourd'hui
merci et tiki
quelle démonstration technologique je
pense que vous avez remarqué deux choses
d'une je vais serrer la main pour
l'activer et 2,2 et vous a fait coucou
il a déclenché chez vous un besoin une
envie d'aller plus loin dans
l'interaction vous dites tiens
maxime il va encore parler à ce robot et
on va voir jusqu'où il peut aller dans
l'interaction
c'est ce réflexe là c'est ce début de
réflexes là que les robots sont capables
de vous faire déclencher et pourtant ce
sont des machines et c'est là toute la
différence par rapport aux outils
informatiques
on a aujourd'hui et même si comme vous
l'expliqué au début aujourd'hui la
technologie est pas parfaite
ce qui pour moi est important dans le
robot sait qu'il nous aide à nous rendre
plus humain merci